we've been considering for a long time
now whether the fact that kovid appears
to have killed more republicans than
democrats is going to have an impact in
the 2022 midterms in the 2024 election
and we are starting to get some of that
data and it is not looking particularly
good for republicans and this brings me
no pleasure
but it's important to recognize that if
covet deaths hurt republicans as a party
it will be as a result of their own
actions and nobody else's
very interesting article on trib live
more republicans have died of covet 19
does that mean the polls are off
very important question doctors and
demographers recently noticed another
tragic example of how polarization
shapes america the pandemic has killed
more people in the nation's republican
enclaves than its democratic strongholds
they explained the gap by pointing to
republican resistance to vaccines of
course
and the republican party's more cavalier
approach to combating the virus in
general the findings suggest many more
republicans tens of thousands
if not hundreds of thousands have died
of covet 19 then democrats leading some
to wonder
what will the political impact be
i've given a lot of thought to this and
i'm going to give you my sense
first a really quick word from our
sponsor morning brew when i'm on my
phone trying to catch up on news i often
find myself sort of aimlessly browsing
feeds on google or social media it's not
really the best use of my time but using
morning brew to absorb news is a
completely different experience morning
brew is a free daily newsletter
delivered seven days a week it gets me
up to speed on business finance tech and
more in just five minutes morning brew
takes the day's most important stories
breaks them down gives you the most
important takeaways once you've looked
at all of your political news
pull up your morning brew newsletter
because it covers everything not just
politics morning brew gives you a 360
degree view on everything from silicon
valley to real estate culture world news
the other day morning brew had a great
three minute read about seven teenagers
in london
arrested for hacking some of the world's
biggest tech companies and morning brews
article told me everything i needed to
know nothing more
that's what it's great for when i'm on
the go on my phone i love how morning
brew has distilled stories down into
something i can read quickly if i have
only a few minutes and don't want to get
bogged down enjoy a brief well-rounded
overview of the news every day of the
week subscribe to morningbrew right now
for free using the link below
alright so
is the partisan covet death gap
going to impact the 2022 midterm
elections the answer is it really
depends in what state we know more
republicans than democrats have died of
coven we it absolutely is clear we don't
know if it's by a margin
of tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands but one example and and you'll
see how close the numbers are starting
to get
is to look at the state of florida state
of florida has had as far as the
official account
73 000 cova deaths if you look at the
2018 florida gubernatorial election
you will find that ron desantis's margin
of victory
was just 33 000 votes 33 000 votes so
73 000 have died in the state of florida
let's imagine for a second there's just
hypothetically let's imagine that of the
73 000
60 percent are republicans 60 now the
dif it might be a bigger difference than
that what that would mean
is that republicans have suffered a net
loss of 29 000 voters in florida due to
cova deaths
29 000 voter net loss
compared to
a 33 000 vote margin of victory for the
republican in 2018. and these are very
rough estimates if the real numbers are
actually 65 percent of florida covered
deaths were republicans
that may start to get now they're not
all voters they're not all adults but
you're starting to get to numbers that
could actually make a difference in a
gubernatorial election but forget about
gubernatorial for a second when we talk
about congressional elections because
remember that all 435 house seats
uh are up for re-election every two
years including this november
those races come down to far fewer
voters than something like the state of
florida and so it is completely
mathematically plausible that
not getting vaccinated at higher rates
uh like democrats
not taking as seriously
as democrats have on average
may actually damage republicans
politically and then it comes the
question of what what does the polling
say and here's why the polling may not
capture this you often hear
the poll uh the sample was account was
adjusted to account for
uh party registration
age all these different things
and the problem is if you've had an
event that has disproportionately killed
republicans rather than democrats you're
normalizing or adjusting your poll
results based on the old populations of
republicans and democrats and so it's
conceivable it's conceivable
that
the current polling for 2022 midterm
elections
doesn't account for the partisan death
gap
all we can really do is wait
but it would be
stunning
if that partisan coveted death gap
actually allowed democrats to keep
control of the house of representatives
let me know your thoughts